my name is Tim Meadows I'm here on
barstool and I am here to tell you about
no activity you'll see a bunch of stuff
about it
CBS XS it's a great comedy show would
you rather go back to 80 years old
knowing everything you know now or get 1
million dollars cash boy well I would
probably take the 1 million dollars cash
because knowing what I know now I know
that I could turn it into like 5 million
in like a week so and what I know now is
cocaine would I rather be stuck in
gymnastic Park or Jumanji I'd rather be
stuck in Jurassic Park because my secret
for surviving in Jurassic Park will be
to just dig a hole I can't you know
they can't go and they can't dig you out
of a hole
you can live underground come up eat
when you want dinosaurs run by do
whatever the [ __ ] they're gonna do you
got your hole that's it what I will
rather watch sports or porn upside down
for the rest of my life yeah we do I
have a choice between porn or sports or
one of them one oh um I would watch porn
upside down because I can still figure
out what's going on would you rather
walk with a roller blade on your left
shoe for the rest of your life a young
one shoe mm-hmm or you have a [ __ ]
walking in front of you
but he's walking just slightly slower
than you and he also has a bad temper
well between the two choices of
rollerblade on my left foot or walking
in front of a slow little person I'd
probably choose the walking in front of
the slow little person because you know
eventually you get to know them a little
bit you could talk them into walking
faster whereas you got a [ __ ] roller
blade on your left foot the rest of your
life which is and it's not fun at all if
you had to eat one human body part what
would it be
vagina
or you means eat and swallow that's
different
oh you have to chew it up and eat it
I would probably probably say like a
probably like an arm yeah probably
either arm cuz I figured be not a lot of
fat if his muscular you know probably
would taste good and also is like you're
eating with somebody it's like having a
you know another hand like holding a
napkin or something though would you
rather sleep in a bed with sand in it
for the rest of your life more you pee
the bed three or four times a week I get
to pee in the bed four times a week you
get to if you want to but yeah oh no
okay so you either you pee more four
times a week or there's just sand in
your bed every time every for the rescue
way ooh boy well I wouldn't want sand in
my bed all the time cuz it just reminds
me back when I was dating Pamela
Anderson so that's not guys sad memories
so I will take pee in the bed because
then I just want to clarify I get to pee
in the bed yeah and nobody goes oh you
peed in the bed I take the pee in the
bed and rather than the sand into bed
okay okay a choice between a sum of
money and world peace how much money
would it take for you to not choose
World Peace I would probably say
whatever the Amazon dude Jeff Bezos
whatever he has double that and yeah so
250 billion what I figured with two
billion I could even build my own if the
world really sucks there's gonna be
destroy I could just build a you know
like a spaceship and just go living or
digging oh that's a good one I'd say a
rewind button it goes back to the
question of if I know what I know now
and I could take it back which I would
guess is with a rewind button because
I'm operating it so I would say rewind
button cuz it'd be nice to go back
here's the question no can you go back
and change it with the rewind button or
do you just go back and just relive it
again
you're it just plays the same TV show
back yes I was thinking the rewind with
ends butterfly effects stuff in your fix
this I won't be an [ __ ] this one time
right but then where does that leave me
with
the set but the thing is is that when
you you could always rewind to get
things that you'd like that happened to
pass and skip over bad things you know
I'm saying so I think I would still go
for the rewind because I still have
power over what I could rewind so I
would just I wouldn't go back to relive
sad things I would go back and relive
like happy thing yeah the cocaine or
eating of a jam